[Musique]
je me trouve actuellement au domaine de
d'empyr ans neeve in situ en vallée de
chevreuse ici à les parcs et jardins ont
été réalisés par le paysagiste andré le
nôtre ce château du xviie siècle que
vous voyez derrière moi a été réalisé
par jules hardouin mansart l'architecte
du château de versailles on va aller le
découvrir dans quelques instants mais
tout de suite ont rejoint pascal teva le
directeur du domaine détenu par franky
mulliez c'est au cours du 19ème siècle
que il ya une grande restauration qui a
été menée et qui a un peu chamboulé
l'image que jules hardouin mansart
voulait en données puisque l'architecte
du banc qui avaient beaucoup restaurer
les patrimoines en france est bien
intervenu lui-même à dampierre et il a
donc apporté une touche supplémentaire
notamment par des changements de
parti-pris de teintes d'enduit et autres
[Musique]
des travaux de restauration débuté en
février 2020 et nous on va les découvrir
ce chantier de l'intérieur quelques
niveaux d'échafaudages à monter et on va
arriver sur les toits ou principalement
là il ya les travaux de couverture et de
charpente et mais au fur et à mesure
d'aller découvrir et bien les travaux
des maçons des menuisiers autre combat
suivez-moi
là on est complètement dans les
entrailles du château voyez derrière moi
il ya une partie complètement éventré où
on voit les pièces des greniers qui
apparaissent ou alors on voit les
tuyauteries les chauffages abandonné et
c'est donc tout ça on est dans les
entrailles que les plus complètes c'est
ce qui par contre préserve le bâtiment
puisque ses entrailles c'est le
squelette du château ce sont les murs
c'est la charpente très peu de
remplacement puisque on privilégie une
restauration qui soit qui préserve
l'existant et donc ce fronton et bien on
recolle du petit morceau où elle
vraiment on retravaille très finement
sur cet ouvrage car
j'étais en fait les gens d'un break
généralement inaccessibles ah oui oui
oui là on nous évoluons aujourd'hui sur
le chantier à proprement parler
complètement isolée de la visite que
l'on fait avec le public par mesure de
sécurité ou le public évolue lui dans un
site côte mon propre serre qui n'a pas
l'embarras les machines des matériaux
est ici vous voyez vous êtes encore plus
près de l'oeuvre puisque là on a devant
nous cette lucarne qui vient d'être
restaurée on aperçoit les bois neuf les
bois anciens des greffes fin tout était
voilà les compagnons charpentiers
restaure cette lucarne
dans le dessein du xviie siècle sous le
contrôle de la chaîne de notre
architecte en chef des monuments
historiques
[Musique]
vous l'aurez compris l'objectif ici
remplacé les éléments abîmé et préserver
le décor cette partie et n'est pas
accessible au public mais des visites
guidées sont organisées auprès du
chanteur
[Musique]